tengo la función igual a x menos 3 al
cuadrado por x menos uno y lo que quiero
hacer es rotar la parte positiva de esta
función la parte que está entre x igual
a 1 y x igual a 3 que son claramente los
ceros de esta función las raíces de esta
función y quiero tomar esta región
quiero tomar esta región y rotarla
alrededor del eje que y si hago eso voy
a obtener una figura que se ve como esto
el problema es entonces calcular el
volumen de esta figura y para esto te
voy a presentar un nuevo método
denominado cascarones método de
cascarones bueno tú podrías decir ya
hemos calculado volúmenes cuando rotamos
alrededor de ejes verticales para eso
utilizamos el método de discos
obteníamos la función en términos de jay
calculamos el volumen de cada disco pero
la razón por la cual vamos a usar un
nuevo método es que esta función no la
podemos obtener en términos de y no es
posible despejar x en términos de i de
esta expresión en vez de eso dejaremos
la función en términos de x y
estableceremos un razonamiento
geométrico distinto para obtener el
volumen nos vamos a imaginar que
desde construir discos vamos a construir
cascarones y qué es un cascarón bueno
para cada valor de x para cada valor de
x vamos a construir un rectángulo vamos
a construir un rectángulo y qué pasa si
lo rotamos bueno aquí tenemos el mismo
rectángulo y qué pasa si este rectángulo
junto con toda la región lo rotamos
alrededor del eje y bueno veamos lo voy
aquí aplicar mis dotes de artista para
ver cómo queda ese rectángulo cuando lo
giramos aquí lo tenemos no está muy bien
bueno sí sí se ve si se ve la idea como
puedes ver es un cilindro delgado al
cual llamamos cascarón precisamente va a
tener cierto espesor de x es el espesor
el espesor del cascarón es de x este
espesor que tenemos aquí es
x y la altura la altura va a ser el
valor de la función f x en este caso es
x 3 al cuadrado por x menos uno cómo
calculamos entonces el volumen de un
cilindro como estos bien veamos la
geometría de este cascarón si calculamos
el valor de esta circunferencia y lo
multiplicamos por la altura vamos a
estar obteniendo básicamente el área
superficial externa de este cilindro y
si esta área superficial externa la
multiplicamos por el espesor
infinitesimal que le estamos llamando de
x obtendremos el volumen de este
cilindro el volumen del cascarón hagamos
eso cuál es la circunferencia del
cascarón bueno la circunferencia la
circunferencia del cascarón va a ser
igual a 2 p2p por el radio del cascarón
y esta que va a ser igual bueno esto va
a ser necesitamos expresar esto con
función de x esto es igual a 2 pi por
cuánto vale el radio el radio es la
distancia del eje i
el punto x donde está el cascarón esa
distancia corresponde al valor de x por
lo que la circunferencia el cascarón es
igual a 2 pi por x ahora cuál es la
altura en cualquiera de esos cascarones
bueno la altura la altura del cascarón
va a ser igual simplemente la función fx
esa va a ser la altura del cascarón y
como calculamos el área superficial
externa como calculamos el área
superficial y deje poner entre comillas
externa por lo pronto no estoy tomando
en cuenta el espesor de x no considera
esta parte de arriba ni la de abajo sólo
estamos considerando el área superficial
externa así que en este caso el área
superstición externa va a ser el valor
de la circunferencia que tenemos aquí
que es 2 px por la altura que es f x y
en este caso en particular la función f
x aquí la tenemos esto va a ser igual a
2 y x x x menos 3 al cuadrado por x
menos 1 y cuál va a ser entonces el
volumen bien el volumen el volumen del
cascarón va a ser igual a esta expresión
que es el área superficial externa por
el espesor que es de x es decir 2 px por
fx de x y ya estamos listos para
integrar entonces el volumen de nuestra
figura el volumen de nuestra figura va a
ser igual a la integral la integral
sobre este intervalo que va de 1 a 3
entonces es la integral de 1 a 3 del
volumen del cascarón que obtuvimos aquí
2 pi lo va a sacar del integral entonces
va a ser igual a 2 x integral de 1 a 3
de esta expresión que ya desarrollamos x
por fx lo cual va a ser
por equis menos 3 al cuadrado por x
menos 1 y por supuesto por de x esto de
x hielo aquí ya hemos obtenido una
integral definida por el método de
cascarones para calcular el volumen de
esta extraña figura